are you ready for our next story no
because I will not participate in the
tearing down of a successful woman an
article dropped that the Kelly Clarkson
show is a traumatizing workplace run by
monster right and so when you read that
headline who would you assume is the
monster at the top of the Kelly Clarkson
show Kelly right and Kelly being evil is
quite literally unbelievable Kelly would
have to walk up to me and punch me in
the face even then even as I say it was
involuntary spots no even then I would
say I probably needed it put out like
some text on font right and said like
that she had no idea and obviously that
she doesn't stand for any of this of
course we knew that she didn't I just I
can't believe she had to like wake up
and post that and I think it's more of a
statement on society that we got to a
place where Kelly Clarkson had to do
that and act at such like a low brow
like disgusting level of behavior